I was sharing the economic council it's
called ECOFIN and it is kind of the
house of 27 member states
it's where ministers meets from each
country where compromise is made and
when that compromise is made on the
basis of a proposition from the
Commission then we will negotiate with
the European Parliament it is a
challenge you're chairing a meeting in
another language with new colleagues and
some of the issues that we are debating
of a very complex nature so the
interplay between the president chairing
the colleagues around the table and all
the employees and the staffs around us
is very delicate we had a very high
priority file from the Commission it was
concerning how should our financial
institution how should banks work in the
future and there was a lot of different
interests but there was also the
momentum that maybe today we can reach
an agreement the file that we were
negotiating for this ya 1015 hours is a
volume of I think 700 pages so it's of
crucial importance that our staff have
done their job so we had the meeting
around the table we broke up had a pause
went into smaller meetings people was
going and coming discussing in smaller
groups back to the table figuring out
then how to take it from here and the
reason why it took so long was that we
still said this now we were adding we're
close maybe maybe maybe we can reach the
consensus today and we became very very
close at the end of the meeting in the
middle of the night we had a consensus
between a huge qualified majority and
then we said this is it now we have 14
days in order to make sure that we got
everything right
negotiate always depend on good
preparation knowing what you want to
achieve but also knowing where can I
make a compromise
you